- Check it, clouds and dirt.
(laughs)
I'm actually opening with that now.
(upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
(cheering)
I just want to go to Cheebo.
Don't you want to go to Cheebo?
(upbeat music)
♪ Say my name louder now ♪
♪ Keep that energy when I come to town ♪
♪ Don't waste my time ♪
- [Gary] Hi, how are you?
- I used to help book all your stuff when
I was at CAA.
- [Gary] No shit?
That's amazing.
- Yeah, I was working with Peter--
- [Both] And Adler and all those guys.
- [Gary] That's awesome man.
- I saw you and Adler linked up.
- Yes, we linked up.
- That's fucking awesome dude.
- It's great to see you man.
Miles, what up my man?
What up, what up, what up?
- How you doin' my boy?
- My man, good to see you, how are you?
- All good, all good.
- What up my dude?
- You know you're the dope.
- Good to see you.
- What up man, how are you?
Real pleasure.
- Hey, these mother
fuckers right here though--
- I like your shoes.
- You like them, I saw
dude give me some love.
- These mother fuckers right here--
- Thank you my dude.
Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
Hello everyone, hi, hi, hi.
♪ Got my hands clapped together,
I've been prayin' for this ♪
♪ I've been takin' shots forever
it's been hit or a miss ♪
- Guess what, I'm about to go on Network,
and sell, for the first time ever,
the black Clouds and Dirt.
Download the app.
Why don't you go through the chat and help
people understand what
the fuck we're doing.
So what, they can just download the app?
- [Man] Yes, IOS only.
- It's, it's only iPhone?
That's good, cause fucking Android sucks.
(shouting)
I'm just kidding, I'm
kidding, I'm kidding.
I just wanted people to look up.
I hate Android, by the way,
there's only one reason on Earth
why I hate Android.
Hey Andrew, Andy, tell everyone the story
about when you decided to go rouge
and get Android.
How long did you own Android phone?
- [Andrew] One day.
- Why, what happened?
- [Andrew] iMessage.
- So--
- I sent a text message.
Immediately, he didn't respond
to anything other than,
please don't tell me you
bought an Android phone.
- I was like, why's your shit green?
Why's your shit green?
And green's my favorite color,
so imagine how much I hate that.
You know why it is
though, you'll love this,
the only reason nobody
on my team has Android,
is because I have to be able to text while
I'm on WiFi on planes,
'cause that's where I do all my work.
And if I can't text you,
oh Caleb you were Android too!
- [Caleb] No not since I was eight, no.
- Oh no, who?
- [Caleb] Jake.
- Jake, fucking Levy.
Want me put this up?
- Yes.
- Awesome.
Thank you so much.
- You encouraged me to start my YouTube,
to start my Instagram channel,
in six weeks we got 40,000.
- Good for you.
- I'm serious.
- That makes me happy.
- I'm grind like I'm Gary Vee.
- I love it man, congrats.
- I do, I do.
- Congrats, congrats.
- When I was like, how the hell
am I gonna figure this Internet?
I was like--
- Thank you.
- I've been watching your stuff.
- That makes me so happy, keep doing it.
- You rock, you rock.
- Thank you.
Hey, thanks for having
me, nice to meet you.
- Oh my god, of course, thanks for coming.
- Yeah, I'm super excited about it.
- I'm so excited.
- Yeah, it's gonna be awesome.
- Yay.
- It's gonna be cool,
looking forward to it.
Yo, what up everybody?
Going on Network live to sell the new
Clouds and Dirt.
Dark Sky, Dark Clouds, right?
Dark Clouds.
I've changed the name so many times.
Only way to get it, internationally,
20 minutes, be ready.
Everybody, it's Gary Vee,
we're going live 6:00 PM PST,
9:00 PM EST.
Check it, Clouds and Dirt.
- [Man] You have to do that again.
- I'm doing it, I'm actually
opening with that now.
I'm gonna open with that.
Me and Jordan have been working,
we've been working, exactly.
(hip hop music)
So the 03, the first version
was the white color way.
- Right.
- Clouds and Dirt, kind
of my thesis on life.
Right, have a macro
vision, all the big stuff,
but then you gotta get your hands dirty
and put in the work.
Be in the studio.
Be the entrepreneur,
put in the actual work.
So many people talking about clouds,
but not willing to do the dirt these days
on fake entrepreneurs on Instagram.
So I wanted to put this out, and then
Barney, the team, Tyler
and the rest of my crew
they're like hey, lets do
a secret kinda color way.
And lets do a black on the reverse.
And then I was thinking about it,
I wanted to do it, but then I was like,
what are we gonna call it?
And then calling it Dark
Clouds got me excited,
because I think the
biggest thing that people
don't talk about with entrepreneurship
is that 99% of it is shit,
and lonely, and tough,
and bad, and dark.
- Right.
- And so, I'm in a weird way, I associate
even more with that part of the journey
that nobody wants to talk about
- [Both] On social.
- Right.
So lets talk about, you're very positive.
- Yeah.
- So I want to talk to both of you,
I'm sure you get, there's a lot of hate,
there's a lot of negativity.
- I'm learning from him,
I'm learning from him.
- So how do you deal with it?
Because does it ever get to your head?
Does it get you down?
- You know for me it's like, look,
I think when somebody
leaves negativity on a post
on social media, that's an indicator about
them, not me.
- For sure.
- Like, I have never, nor will I ever,
take time to consume somebody's content,
and then leave some hate.
- Right.
- That's just a complete waste of time.
So honestly,
I look at it with compassion and empathy.
When I see that stuff, I just feel bad--
- Right.
- That somebody's on a
place where they need
to drag somebody down.
And so for me, negativity and fear,
they can have a little
love, in the short term.
You can win a little with that game.
But long term positivity and love
always wins the game.
What I wanna say real quick is--
- Yeah.
- If your not buying this shoe right now
and swiping whatever
functionality this app does
you got that down.
- Shopping cart below.
- Shopping cart below, if
you're not buying this,
you're breaking my heart.
- [All] Awe.
- And for all the people flippin',
buy like 10 and flip 'em
and I'll give you exposure.
- Yeah.
- Yes, you are for reselling?
- Of course I'm for reselling,
that's how I grew up.
I hate when people become hypocrites,
when they resold, and
when they were coming up,
stood in line and flipped.
But when they got their own shit,
they were like, ah.
I only want people to buy, honestly,
this is like one, this one we've only,
I think we only made 5,000.
Like, I want everybody's
watching right now
buy it, relist it on eBay for $200,
and I'll give you
exposure, make your money.
- Wow, I love that.
- I got my pair.
(laughing)
And I need a signature.
Right here buddy, yeah.
- Oh you want the, you want the $400 flip.
- You hear me.
- I love it, 'cause so
many in the sneaker world
are anti-reselling, they think it ruins--
- That blows my fucking mind.
- Yeah.
- People that are
anti-reselling are literally
just hating on people that are,
like, I don't understand that logic.
- Right.
- Like, look by the way,
if people wanna wear 'em, great.
But is somebody else wants 'em more,
and you can't get 'em, the best,
the reason why I wanted
to do this with Network
this is now available internationally.
Otherwise we're not.
- Right.
- So if somebody watching
right now in Australia
or U.K. or things of that nature,
this is the only way.
- This is the only place they can.
- So, as you can imagine,
and it's a $50 shipping point,
so they're in for a buck 50, right?
But I know they can get $330.
And I want them to make that 180 bucks.
'Cause if that matters more to them than
rocking it, that's them.
Everyone's selfish.
Like you hurt my feelings.
It's fucking ridiculous.
- Yeah, grow up.
- Straight up.
- For real.
- I feel like the younger
generation is so like
into being so negative.
Like they think it's cool to be sad.
- Yeah, I mean look.
Emo, and like that, there's always that.
- They have a voice now,
we didn't have a voice that much.
- 100%, every 13, 16, 19 year old,
always have angst.
The problem is, is that people just
don't have a perspective, like they don't
understand it's impossible
to be a human being.
Like it's impossible.
- Right.
- Like that's the rarest
shit in the world.
And so they just people
taking for granted,
take it for granted, take it for granted.
- Yeah.
I love your energy.
- Thanks.
(laughing)
- [Man] All right, we're clear.
All clear.
- Yeah.
- That was the craziest exit
I've ever heard in my life.
That was the most basic shit ever.
- That was the best show we've done yet.
- That was amazing.
- Thank you.
- Hey, congratulations
- Thank you, Michael
I'm so glad we got all
exposure for you.
- Appreciate you, thank you.
♪ Again, again, again, again ♪
- This is what I respect.
Flip gangsters out there Andy.
People making, guy's got it up for $600.
- Gangster.
- $575 a pair.
People tryin' to make that money.
- [Man] Woo
- What's your view now
on the sneaker business?
Since you've really done
a deep dive into it?
- Look I mean, you know, first of all
being in the sneaker business is the best.
I'll tell you why.
It's so established as
a anchor in our lives,
I think sneakers are
no different than being
in the jeans business for the last
like, you know, 70 years.
Like, it's not going anywhere,
the vulnerabilities are
too much fragmentation,
too much non actual brand building.
I think that one of the things
that I've been cautious of,
that I've been trying to
be a great partner of,
is how much love I give K-Swiss.
You know like of course
they're gonna get it,
like tagging always,
and like always like bringing you guys up,
and like it's important to me to be
that good of a partner.
So I think finding the right balance for
the brand is important.
But what do I see?
Look, I think that there's
an amazing opportunity,
for a lot of people to
carve out the long tail.
And that's what's happening
in every business.
I think there's an incredible opportunity
to lean in heavier, to
some of these boutiques,
and micro franchises.
So to me, the guys and gals opening up six
or seven stores at a time are interesting
while supporting the big players that
we all work with on the sale side.
I think there's an opportunity to tap in
even heavier to long tail influencers.
And I think there's opportunities
to be ultra creative.
Like, I've been thinking
a lot of stuff of like,
what if I made a sneaker
that was biodegradable,
where my whole pitch
was wear them for a week
and then bury 'em in the ground?
Like what if my sneaker became a tree?
A tree.
Listen innovate.
- Bryan, you need to
start working on that.
- Listen innovation is wild
and you just never know.
And like as people become
more thoughtful about
the environment and things that nature
Like trends, trends.
Sports, you know we've
talked a lot about that.
Thank you for having me guys.
Take care, thank you.
♪ I be dreamin' ♪
- Did I do a good job?
- You fucking smoked it.
- Yeah?
- To be honest yeah.
- [Gary] Yeah.
♪ Could get you back up baby
'cause I need you again ♪
♪ Again, again ♪
- No, you were right.
I'm like, why are we going to 13?
I would walk to 13,
but I think we're going to two.
♪ Black lingerie and the white Ferrari ♪
- Look at that.
- What's up, real pleasure man.
Real pleasure.
What up, I know a lot
of you that I fuck with
are gonna be at Complex Con.
Tyler and I are plotting right now.
Hit up Tyler, I'm tagging him right now,
I wanna see you come by the booth,
or I'll come to you.
There's a bunch of you that I know
wanna take that photo,
or give that love to.
♪ Again, again, need you again ♪
- I wanna live in L.A. sometimes.
Right?
The weather's legit.
- The weather.
- I'm clearly buying a
place when the economy
collapses in L.A.
100,000%.
- Yeah?
- 100,000%.
For me, I'm just like,
I'm in constant move.
Like, you know, January, April, lets go.
- Yeah you don't even
think about the five hours.
- I don't think about anything.
I'm just like, don't fucking think.
♪ I'm like ya, try'na come
over for the night ya ♪
♪ Baby lemme know if it's alright ya ♪
(applause)
- I think one of the things I'm
most fascinated by right now
is there's so much money in the system
and if you follow where
the money comes from
that's an interesting thing to debate
in the first place.
But lets leave that for another day.
I am fascinated by people thinking that
not making more profit than expenses
is not something you need
to think about a lot more.
Like, I'm just watching
people spend all their time
on like, you know, influencer marketing
and Kak and M.N.A and like all this stuff,
I'm like when the money dries out,
there's a lot of young
people in the system.
You didn't live through
2007 as an operator,
you were in college, having fun.
You didn't live through 2001.
We have never been this over leveraged.
And when the dominoes fall and there's no
next fundraising round,
or when you're an influencer and nobody's
got $8,000 for you to take a picture
with a fucking toothpaste in your hand.
(audience laughing)
It's not going to be fun to go from
traveling the world as an influencer,
to no money in the system and you have
to go get a job.
Like, I want people to be prepared
and everyone's living
in fucking lala land.
And we've been living in
lala land for a decade.
Which makes me nervous as fuck.
Thank you.
♪ Again, again, again, again ♪
- Six years ago, I gave
you a two dollar bill
in New York City at Google
and you were talking.
And I wrote, buy the Jet's fund
and I said I want to add to your fund,
this is the second time I've seen you--
- Four dollars.
- In six years, you got four bucks.
- Love it bro, love you Jeremy.
Thank you so much man.
- But to help people see the experience
they gotta like embody it.
- But brother, you got 22 year olds who'd
rather have the coolest sneakers
and so they have to do
things for economics.
They don't understand that's burning
the bridges for what they actually want.
- Right,
- Look, I'm an entrepreneur,
I wanna build businesses that make money.
But there's such a way
to do it in a right way,
it's just lacking patience.
People lack fucking patience.
- Right, right.
- It's short, and then
if you take it a seed
lower, people care about
other people's opinions.
And so they do behaviors to
look good to other people.
- [Man] Right.
- It's super interesting to me, as I've,
you know, I'm not a kid that learns
through education, I have to live it.
And I'm like, oh, oh you're doing,
oh you're doing that 'cause you want
a million dollars today
and I want $300,000
over 20 years.
Okay, I understand.
Oh, you want a million
today 'cause you wanna
fuckin' take a private
jet to get the girl.
Oh, okay.
Like, you know you start to like, oh shit
your parents made you insecure, you know,
like it's some deep shit for me.
- I meant to ask you,
what's the five about?
- It's my favorite number,
literally it's that basic.
- I feel like it's like oh no--
- It's that basic
- I want all of it, you know all--
- Oh, yeah.
We goin'?
♪ I'mma pull up on ya ♪
- Ultimately, you have the ability to take
something from zero to 1000.
- Correct.
- You know?
And it's like inner
circle homies like these
characters who are like disproportionately
IP'd out on my way.
Who are like, it's just
cliche, right like,
they didn't look the part but then they
run the whole ship.
Like, it's happening in Vayner right now.
- I'm watching DRock at
home right now, I love it.
I'm like it's fucking DRock online.
- You're all set.
- I'm like DRock is his own mother fucker.
- 100%
He's a fucking verb.
- And he's, it's great.
- It's the best.
- And it's like, but I guess that's--
- That's the beauty, and by the way.
Back to kindness, people don't understand,
kindness is the stickiest
part of keeping talent.
- Yeah.
- I just want to go to Cheebo.
(upbeat music)